[Music]
have you ever thought about
how each of us got to where we are today
i've often asked myself what are all the
things that i did right to get into an
ivy league college
and then earn a six figure salary as a
21 year old
well turns out all i really had to do
right
was to be born into the right household
and right neighborhood
from then on the odds were in my favor
unlike many of us here today
tashana murphy was not so lucky
taishana grew up in new york city public
housing until the age of 18
when she was gunned down in the hallway
outside her home
her friends were wrapped up in a gang
rivalry
she had suffered an asthma attack the
day before
something that disproportionately
affects children living in substandard
housing
and couldn't run away fast enough
she was a star basketball player and
would have been the first
person in her family to go to college
through a community development
corporation i was working with at the
time
i met tishana's dad we gathered
in a makeshift meeting space in west
harlem
a block away from where tijana was
killed
he stood in front of me
side by side with the mother of
t'shauna's killer
an unfathomable alliance their pain
suppressed by their resolve to end the
vicious cycle
of losing their sons and daughters to
early graves
literally or figuratively at the hands
of the nypd together
they pleaded for after-school programs
a basketball court a new community
center
all of which i took for granted growing
up
unfortunately for children living in
poverty
tashana's story is the rule
not the exception because where you grow
up
makes you who you are
this is not a talk about the failures of
the criminal justice system though
and that certainly plays a role
this is about a feature with better
neighborhoods
as the pathway to change let's start
with evidence
harvard economist raj chetty used tax
records
to track virtually every american born
in the late 70s
to early 80s there are three findings i
want to share with you
first poverty is intergenerational
a child born poor will only have a 7.5
percent chance
of becoming rich
second children born into poverty
are more affected by where they grow up
some places lifted them out of poverty
but most trapped them but those rare
places
that fostered upward mobility have four
characteristics in common
they were integrated had a mix of
incomes and races
have better schools greater social
capital
and more stable family structures
and finally access to opportunity
is unequal fewer than five percent
of black children grew up in
environments that better their long-term
prospects
and it's not just about economic
outcomes
where you grow up also affects the most
fundamental
of measures life expectancy
today in chicago just a few subway stops
can result in a 16-year difference in
life expectancy at birth
in new orleans a baby born in the
poorest neighborhood will live
25 years less than a baby born just
four miles away in the most affluent
neighborhood
i have to admit it wasn't until i was a
freshman at brown
after i had spent time tutoring students
in olneyville in providence
that began to scratch the surface of
understanding
how environment can undermine a child's
long-term prospects
the tale of two cities plays out in
providence
two up on college hill
lies my alma mater nestled amongst
quintessential new england homes frozen
in time
under the protective blanket of historic
preservation laws
down the hill lies olneyville
a largely hispanic neighborhood where
more than 40 percent of families live
below the poverty line
olneyville was hit hard by the subprime
mortgage crisis
block after block of foreclosures houses
boarded up
yards overgrown with weeds
shattered glass and broken siding strung
all over
from vandalism and squatting by drug
users
the despondent air outside was stifling
if this was the reality that i woke up
to
and saw outside the classroom window
every single day
the concentration of neglect
what kind of future would i dare to
imagine for myself
would i still have been able to beat the
odds if the odds
say that there's a greater chance for
incarceration than graduating high
school
these questions have stayed with me for
the past 12 years
driving my career decisions from
studying urban planning to leaving my
consulting job
to work on bringing more affordable
housing schools and child care centers
to underserved areas of new york city
looking ahead i want to offer a new
paradigm
from my own childhood from the age
of 9 to 19 i lived through what it meant
to be poor after my family immigrated to
the u.s
my dad was a phd student supporting us
on ten thousand dollars a year
i received free and reduced lunch at
school
and my mom's weekly ritual was counting
tips
she received from waiting tables at the
local chinese restaurant
one of the few places that would take
informal workers like her
yet the affordable housing community
that i lived in
bred connection and promise
outside of every building there were
playgrounds with swing sets
that became the go-to place for heart to
hearts with my best friend
long into the night there was a
community center where my friends and i
would gather for movies
crafts and english practice with
volunteer tutors
families moved a little bit further
after saving enough to afford their own
town homes or houses
but that meant my parents could always
count on having someone to help out with
the bills on a rainy day
and i could count on continuing to see
my friends at school
i recognized that my option of living in
affordable housing affiliated with
university where my dad was getting his
phd
is in itself a privilege
that's exactly the problem
the ability to live in environments that
better our long-term prospects
shouldn't just be for the few with the
right family background or skin color
it should be for everyone
join me in realizing this vision
of course i don't expect you to pursue
careers in community development or
urban policy as i have though i'd be
thrilled
and if you haven't already done so i'd
encourage you
to give back to communities that you
have connections to
instead i want all of us to re-examine
whether some of the things that we hold
dear are actually perpetuating the
status quo
our desire to preserve peace and
character in our own neck of the woods
could that be shutting out entire
classes of people and skin colors
our drive to give our children the best
education possible
could that be depriving local public
schools of much needed resources
and political capital and finally
our affinity for like-minded individuals
could that be numbing our compassion
towards the plight
of others are we
all complicit can we each
contribute more
our prospects in life shouldn't be left
to the sheer
chance of the neighborhood or household
that we're born into because where you
grow up
makes you who you are we need to work
together to
end the tide to turn the tide of the
punishing effects
of intergenerational poverty we need to
end the tale of two cities join me
in changing destiny one neighborhood
at a time